how did I get here and by here
I mean a homeschool mom before I can tell you
we need to go back to where it all began
a few years ago
I was a classroom teacher and getting a master's degree in school administration
and that is when I Learned that schools were not created for kids
and I kind of Learned all of the ins and outs
things that happen behind the scenes
and I was not really a fan of it
throughout my entire teaching career
I had code teachers who are very pro homeschooling
I was not I was very pro school
but I had them in the back of my mind
fast forward to 2020 2021 school year
we all know what happened
and now I'm getting ready to put my kindergartener into a school
where they don't know what the next school year is going to look like
they don't know what mandates
and all of these things are going to look like for the next school year
so I was already hesitant
but my daughter was going to school
we signed up for a kindergarten tour at the same school where I taught
at the same school my husband had gone to elementary through high school
this was our comfort zone
and we knew that this was going to be the best fit for our daughter
also at this time
there was some like
questionable moral stuff happening at schools
we all know what I'm talking about
but I just wasn't about to expose my daughter to all those things
but it's a private Christian school
we thought we weren't gonna deal with that
except those are the exact conversations we heard from students
while we were walking around on our tour
throughout the whole tour
I'm kind of feeling uneasy
like I thought that this was 100% the option that we were going to choose
but something just in my spirit wasn't sitting right
and I didn't know like
I thought I was the only one failing this
because I didn't wanna let go of my baby
I had been her mom and her teacher for five years now
and like I felt like maybe it was just me wanting to give up control
but then we got in the car and the first words out of my husband's mouth were
I think you should homeschool
I looked at this man like he was nuts
I did not want to homeschool
I was like let's tour some other schools first
cause that's not on the table
so we went home we prayed about it for
and also just a few days and I had Amy Morgan in the back of my mind homeschool
homeschool so here we are now
I homeschool both my kids
and it is the best thing that I have ever done